Targaryen civil war that divided Targaryen
dynasty and the entire Westeros in two, is
the main event of House of the Dragon.
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
Thats Fire And Blood volume 1.
The yet unreleased Fire And Vlood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
Key event of the prequel will be the Dance
of the Dragon, a Targaryen civil war.
It was a war of succession between Rhaenyra
(and her Blacks) and Aegon (and his Greens).
The blacks, previously known as the party
of the princess, were the faction of House
Targaryen and their loyalists who supported
the ascent of Rhaenyra Targaryen as Queen
of the Seven Kingdoms during the Dance of
the Dragons and the years that preceded it.
They were opposed by the greens.
The title derives from a great tournament
held in 111 AC at King's Landing on the fifth
anniversary of King Viserys I's marriage to
Queen Alicent Hightower, his second wife.
At the opening feast, Queen Alicent wore a
green gown, whilst Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen,
Viserys's daughter by his first wife, dressed
dramatically in Targaryen red and black.
Note was taken, and thereafter it became the
custom to refer to “greens” and “blacks”
when talking of the queen’s party and the
party of the princess.
Generally, Rhaenyra was supported by noble
families who had enjoyed royal favor during
her father's reign and possessed strong ties
to the crown, while Aegon II rallied those
who had been out of favor.
Viserys I had signed charters with many powerful
Houses in which they swore to accept Rhaenyra
as his heir, but at least some of them broke
their word after Viserys died.
Obviously the most prominent of the Blacks
is its leader and the person they are all
fighting for, Rhaenyra Targaryen.
Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen, cheered as the
Realm's Delight when she was young and later
called the Half-Year Queen, was the first-born
child of King Viserys I Targaryen.
Rhaenyra was King Viserys I's only living
child by his first wife, Queen Aemma of House
Arryn.
At the age of eight she was made her father's
heir and grew up expecting to become the first
ruling Queen of Westeros.
Rhaenyra was a dragonrider whose mount was
Syrax.
Rhaenyra had her family's Valyrian looks,
wearing her silver-gold hair in a long braid
in the manner of Queen Visenya Targaryen.
Beautiful as a child, Rhaenyra was later declared
by her uncle, Prince Daemon Targaryen, to
be the most beautiful maiden in all the Seven
Kingdoms.
Due to the lack of a male heir, Viserys designated
Rhaenyra as his successor.
Therefore, Rhaenyra was the only female Targaryen
to lay claim to the Iron Throne in her own
right.
After Rhaenyra's mother died, her father remarried
and had several sons by his second wife, Alicent
of House Hightower.
Even so, Viserys still publicly expected his
daughter to succeed him, and when he died,
his official will even stated so.
However, Rhaenyra's younger half-brother,
Aegon, challenged her claim.
He stated that the normal inheritance laws
of the Andals (which formed the basis of the
unified law code in Westeros) called for male-preference
primogeniture, meaning that a younger son
would rightfully inherit before an older daughter.
At the time of her father's death, Rhaenyra
was on Dragonstone awaiting the birth of her
child.
The greens in King's Landing ensured that
the news of Viserys's death did not reach
her until her own supporters in the Red Keep
were dead or imprisoned and Aegon II's coronation
had already occurred.
This began a devastating civil war that tore
apart the Seven Kingdoms, known as The Dance
of the Dragons, as it was the only war in
which both sides had dragonriders.
The war lasted for three years, and by the
time it came to an end nearly all of the Targaryen
dragons had been killed.
The conflict also resulted in the death of
three of Rhaenyra's five sons, as well as
the eldest son of Aegon II.
Rhaenyra's personal sigil was the normal Targaryen
heraldry (a three-headed red dragon on a black
field), quartered with the moon-and-falcon
sigil of House Arryn (for her mother Aemma
Arryn), and the silver seahorse on sea green
of House Velaryon (for her first husband Laenor
Velaryon, as well as for the Velaryons in
general, who were among her major supporters).
During the Dance, her faction used her personal
heraldry as their battle-flag.
While both sides lost much and more in the
war, it is a fact that the Blacks won the
war and it is a fact that Rhaenyra even though
dead by the end of it, also won the war because
its her sons that got the throne not Aegon's,
and the Targaryen line continued through her,
meaning that present time Targaryens are descendants
of Rhaenyra and not of her half-brother Aegon.
Next most prominent of the Blacks is the character
that did the most in this war, the character
that is equally loved and hated in Westeros,
and the Blacks best warrior, general and commander,
the Rogue Prince - Daemon Targaryen.
Daemon Targaryen also known as Prince of the
City, Lord Flea Bottom and the Rogue Prince
had many titles throughout his life: Prince,
Ser, Commander of the City Watch, Master of
coin, master of laws, King of the stepstones
and the narrow sea, protector of the realm.
Daemon was the most contoversial man of his
lifetime, an audacious rogue prince and adventuer
who seemed made of good and evil in equal
measure.
There was never a man so loved and so reviled,
and at a same time, as he was.
During the Dance of the Dragons, as the husband
of his niece Rhaenyra, he supported his wife's
claim, and he was considered by many the most
dangerous man in Westeros.
He was Rhaenyra's second husband, following
Ser Laenor Velaryon and she was his third
wife.
Prince Daemon was the most experienced warrior
of his time and wielded the Valyrian steel
blade Dark Sister.
A dragonrider whose dragon was Caraxes, Daemon
declared himself the King of the Stepstones
and the Narrow Sea.
After giving him 2 daughters, Daemon's second
wife Laena died in 120 AC, trying to birth
him a son who died as well.
In 120 AC Daemon married again, this time
to his niece, Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen.
This marriage was performed suddenly without
the knowledge of King Viserys I Targaryen,
and was scandalous since neither Laena nor
Laenor Velaryon, Daemon's previous wife and
Rhaenyra's previous husband, had been dead
for six months.
According to Mushroom, it was Daemon who arranged
the death of Laenor by paying Ser Correy to
kill him, thus making Rhaenyra available to
marry.
Daemon and Rhaenyra had two sons together,
Prince Aegon the Younger born in 120 AC and
Prince Viserys, born in 122 AC.
At the start of the civil war called the Dance
of the Dragons, Prince Daemon had more experience
in warfare than all their foes combined.
During Rhaenyra's rival coronation on Dragonstone,
Daemon placed the crown of King Jaehaerys
I Targaryen on the head of his wife, proclaiming
her queen and claiming himself Protector of
the Realm.
Daemon led the assault on Harrenhal, capturing
the ruined castle from its castellan.
After hearing of the death of his stepson,
Prince Lucerys Velaryon, at the hands of his
nephew, Prince Aemond Targaryen,
Daemon, through his spymaster and former mistress
Mysaria, hired Blood and Cheese to murder
a son of Aegon II.
Son for a son.
Daemon abandoned Harrenhal when Aemond and
Criston began marching on the great castle
with a host of greens
Instead, Daemon flew Caraxes back to King's
Landing and assisted Rhaenyra with capturing
the city.
He made his niece and wife, Rhaenyra the Queen
of the Seven Kingdoms.
His next and final act in the war and in his
life was the battle above the Gods Eye when
he challenged King Aegon's brother and the
most prominent of the Greens, Aemond One-Eye,
which is the day both, the Blacks and the
Greens lost its best warriors and commanders.
Aemond answered Daemon's challenge, arrived
on legendary dragon Vhagar and the most epic
battle of the entire war was about to start.
When he climbed upon Caraxes, Daemon did not
fasten his chains that connected him.
Since Daemon's dragon was a lot younger and
smaller than Aemond's, Daemon was quickly
hidden in clouds whilst Aemon looked for him.
When Caraxes attacked Vhagar, she ripped upon
his stomach and tore one of his wings, but
then Caraxes fastened his jaws around her
throat in death grip.
These injuries forced them both to cease flying
and as they tumbled to the water below, Daemon
dueled Aemond to the death.
As he never fastened his saddle, Daemon stood
up on Caraxes and leapt at Aemond,
whereupon he drove his Dark Sister through
Aemond's eye and through his neck, just a
second before hitting the water.
The Battle Above the Gods Eye ended in the
deaths of both riders and both dragons.
Daemon was forty-nine when he died.
Unlike Aemond's body, however, Daemon's was
never found.
Singers say that Daemon lived to spend the
rest of his days in secret with Nettles, but
most historians disagree.
House of the Dragon will end this debate between
singers and historians and reveal why Daemon's
body was never found and did he really survive
and live his days out in peace with Nettles.
The next prominent member of the Blacks was
Lord Stark.
Cregan Stark, known as the Old Man of the
North, The Wolf of the North and The Wolf
of Winterfell, was the Lord of Winterfell
and head of House Stark during the Targaryn
civil war.
Upon the death of King Viserys I Targaryen,
Rhaenyra's son Prince Jacaerys Velaryon flew
to Winterfell on his dragon Vermax to gain
the support of the Starks and the north for
his mother Rhaenyra Targaryen's claim to the
Iron Throne.
The alliance, known as the Pact of Ice and
Fire, stated that a Targaryen princess, the
future firstborn daughter of Jacaerys, would
marry his son Rickon.
Cregan pledged his support to the blacks during
the Dance of the Dragons.
After Prince Jacaerys Velaryon secured the
allegiance of the North for his mother Rhaenyra
Targaryen, Lord Cregan Stark sent two thousand
soldiers known as the Winter Wolves south
commanded by his bannerman Lord Roderick Dustin
known as Roddy the Ruin to support the Queen's
claim while he remained in the North to gather
his own banners (due to the vastness of the
North this would take long).
Rhaenyra was killed at Dragonstone by King
Aegon II Targaryen, however, but Cregan with
his army still marched south nontheless in
support of her son, Prince Aegon the Younger.
The war continued between the supporters of
the dead queen and the king's remaining loyalists.
Riverlands, the North and the Vale still supported
the claim of Rhaenyra's son, Aegon III, while
Aegon II only had the Stormlands army able
to defend him.
While Lord Stark moved south with his army
to overthrow Aegon II and place Rhaenyra's
son on the Iron Throne, Lord Borros Baratheon
was marching north with his own banners but
he was defeated on the Kingsroad by the riverlords
known as the Lads before Lord Stark arrived.
Having failed to get the battle he wanted,
Stark nevertheless wanted to punish those
who had supported Aegon II.
He moved his forces to claim King's Landing
where he found that Aegon II had been poisoned
and Aegon III was now king.
Since he was aged eleven, a regency needed
to be established and several lords were vying
for power.
With his formidable presense and character
as well as with his army, Lord Stark was the
most powerful man in King's Landing.
With his newfound power, Lord Stark wanted
to punish those who had supported Aegon II
such as the Baratheons, the Lannisters and
the Hightowers.
However, Lord Corlys Velaryon had already
sent envoys to Oldtown, Storm's End and Casterly
Rock to make peace.
While word of the envoys was being waited
upon, there was another matter that Lord Stark
wanted to deal with: the assassination of
Aegon II.
While he had believed that he had been a usurper
and had been riding south to oust him from
power, Lord Stark did not believe in murdering
him but rather in defeating him on the field
of battle.
He declared that all those who had partaken
in the killing needed to be punished.
His troops arrested several people in the
capital, including Lord Velaryon, Lord Larys
Strong, the Master of Whisperers, and several
members of the Kingsguard.
After these arrests were made, Lord Stark
was appointed Hand of the King by King Aegon
III.
During the day that followed his appointment,
Lord Stark led the trials and execution of
the traitors, sending most to the Wall and
executing a member of the Kingsguard and Lord
Strong who refused to take the black.
Following the traditions of House Stark, Lord
Cregan beheaded them both himself with Ice,
the Valyrian steel greatsword of the Starks.
This event came to be known as the 'Hour of
the Wolf' or the 'Judgment of the Wolf'.
Lord Velaryon escaped execution or sentence
when the king issued an edict that he was
to be spared and returned to his former dignity
as Lord of the Tides.
Cregan married Alysanne Blackwood in exchange
for honoring Aegon III's pardon of Lord Corlys.
Lord Stark resigned as Hand the following
day and left King's Landing for Winterfell.
''The snows are falling in the North and my
place is at Winterfell.'' said Cregan explaining
why he can not stay at King's Landing
It was during Cregan's long reign as Lord
of Winterfell that House Stark's loyalty to
the Iron Throne (doubtful at best prior to
this) became a certainty.
Neither Rhaenyra and her Blacks or Aegon II
and his Greens are remembered well in the
history of the Westeros and many argue that
neither side truly won at the end but it is
a fact that Rhaenyra's loyalists won the war
and Rhaenyra's children got the throne.
Let me know your thoughts about everything:
the prequel, its characters, especially the
Blacks, in the comment section down below.
Also let me know which side you support in
this Targaryen civil war, the Blacks or the
Greens and why.
Thank you so much for watching, hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did make sure to give
it a big thumbs up and I hope to see you in
the next one, peace!